رغم تعديل قانون الطوائف المسيحيه مرتين
خلال القرن الماضي الاول عام
1938 تحت اسمي قانون الطوائف غير المسلمه
رقم اثنين وفي التعديل الثاني في عام 2014
استبدل المشرع قانون الطوائف غير المسلمه
بقانون الطوائف المسيحيه مع تعديلات غير
جوهريه فيما يتصل بالميراث
[موسيقى]
الرحله لم تكن سهله وخاصه ان المجتمع
الاردني متحافظ في الحديث عن فكره تعديل
قانون الارث الذي يحمل في طياته الكثير من
تفاصيل امتلاك اراض واملاك تاريخيه تخص
عشائر وعائلات كبيره اغلب المتضررين من
عدم تعديل القانون رفض ان يتكلم امام
الكاميرا وان يكشف عن هويته حاولنا
التواصل من خلال الاب بسام شحاتيت رئيس
محكمه الروم الارثوذكس مع اكبر عدد منهم
حضرتك
اوكي فانت عندك مخاوف لما بعد عمر طويل
يصير اشي
شو حجم القلق اللي تركوا اياه لا بس يا
دكتور يا دكتور بده يكون عندي الواحد
الشجاعه يوقف ويحكي امام الكاميرا